il est sans conteste la révélation de la
compétition cette année dans les
misérables il raconte les deux premières
journées d'un nouvel équipier de la bac
qui patrouillent dans les quartiers de
montfermeil au contact d'une jeunesse
abandonnée et de policiers aux abois
tout un monde écrasée de soleil parcouru
de tensions raciales religieuses
mafieuse il avait coréalisé le
formidable documentaire à voix haute
mais c'est son premier long métrage de
fiction qui a fait un triomphe mercredi
soir dans la grande salle ici à cannes
pour soir la dja merci beaucoup
alors fait d'être allé voir ce qui s'est
passé l'âge mercredi soir vers 20 heures
quand une phrase de victor hugo est
apparu sur le grand écran à la toute fin
de votre film que la salle s'est éclairé
qu'est ce qui s'est passé dans votre
tête
je ne cache pas que j'étais impressionné
à devoir cette salle debout à applaudir
à crier de joie et tous étaient j'étais
vachement surpris a longtemps j'étais
très fier très fier de le projeter mon
client en fait ça donc d'être en
compétition officielle pour la nommer
trachée c'est une perte énorme même
temps c'est l'aboutissement de vingt ans
de travail j'ai envie de dire donc on
est très content d'être là victor hugo
il torée vous qui a un lien très fort
avec montfermeil qui nous l'expliqué
nous le raconter ouais ça moi j'habite
mon fermer une partie du roman de victor
hugo s'est déroulé à montfermeil
aujourd'hui encore on à la maison les
thénardier à la fontaine jean valjean
donc on a un lien assez fort avec avec
ce roman est aussi jugé
me dis que plus d'un siècle plus tard la
misère est toujours aussi présente sur
ce territoire des gavroches week end ils
ont juste changé un peu de couleurs mais
ça reste les mêmes donc voilà c'est fait
un petit clin d'oeil au roman du corps
vous avez pris le parti de montrer ce
quartier de montfermeil n'ont pas
vraiment de l'intérieur mais à travers
les yeux neufs d'un policier de la bac
originaire de cherbourg donc étranger
outsider pourquoi ce choix qui est assez
inattendu faut quelqu'un vous dit sous
l'eau qui veut donner la parole à ces
jeunes des quartiers
j'ai trouvé intéressant de à travers le
personnage de damien qui connaît pas du
tout l'univers d'harry aubenas damien
brunner bien sûr qui arrive de cherbourg
et connaît pas l'univers de la cité ce
que je raconte c'est que souvent c'est
un cas qui arrive c'est que les
policiers arrivent sur des écoles abyss
ou en provence et ils atterrissent dans
ces quartiers qui connaissent pas du
tout non pas forcément l'expérience donc
forcément c'est je sais que c'est pas
forcément la solution mais c'est ce que
je voulais raconter à travers de ce
personnage damien qui arrive et on
découvre l'univers de la cité à travers
son regard
kazim réserve énormément de surprises
c'est ça qui est passionnant il ya toute
une esthétique inde en retournement de
situation de choc de sousse le coupé ça
c'était une attention vous alliez dès le
départ aulas est venu aussi au fur et à
mesure du tournage alors complètement
après manger travail que mon scénariste
joe joe jordan audio dernier nie tout
était écrit tout été appréciée pour j'ai
dit moi le l'histoire le plus misérable
tout est inspiré de faits réels des
choses qu'ils sont arrivés dans la vie
ou dans ses dents dans la ville mais
proche de mes amis donc à mettre en
scène ça ça facilite les français mais
là aussi en l'occurrence raconter une
histoire
est ce que vous essayez quand même
d'échapper à quelque chose qui pourrait
menacer votre film des clichés des
facilités dans le traitement de ce
territoire aussi qui est devenue un
territoire de cinéma une absence de
complexité je me suis dit parce qu'après
j'ai voulu inviter tous ces clichés
quand je dis souvent la tendance à quand
on parle de la banlieue a ramené
vachement de clichés moi justement j'ai
pu les éviter tous ces clichés skimming
livres films sur la banlieue où je
traite pas de drogue je ne traite pas
d'armé pas qu'aucune arme à feu dans le
film j'ai avant tout envie de parler de
l'humain envie de parler de l'enfance
parce que mon film parlant tout de
l'enfance la place des enfants dans ces
quartiers difficiles c'est quoi leur
avenir c'est quoi leur classe et pas que
des enfants et aussi tout les
personnages qui gravitent autour sur les
personnages du maire figure emblématique
dans le quartier où le fémur du
trafiquant qui est la passe donc voilà
c'est de faire une panel de différents
personnages qu'ils graphique gravitent
dans ces quartiers c'est vrai qu'on a ce
point de vue
ras du sol qui celui du policier
interprété par damien bonnart dont vous
parliez est un autre point de vue quand
même qui est beaucoup plus aérien qui
est souvent filmé par drones commandé
par le jeune buzz à l'assembly que votre
fils je suis mon fils ce qui offre à la
fois un autre angle une vision surplombe
lente et une réflexion ici que je dois
dire est assez magnifique sur la façon
de filmer le petit buzz c'est vous oui
quelque part ce moi ce que je raconte
c'est que pendant plus de cinq ans j'ai
fait du coach dans ma cité où je suis
mais les policiers pendant leur
intervention
jusqu'au jour j'ai filmé leurs ébats
vers policière donc j'ai diffusé la
vidéo sur internet la presse a repris en
quête de l'hygiène
c'est la première fois que les policiers
étaient suspendus suite à une une vidéo
qui a été diffusée sur le net quelques
passes à ses premiers s'ils s'étaient
pas mon premier film mais voilà c'était
le point de départ du
des misérables du court métrage et qu'il
faudrait développer par la suite en long
métrage mais c'est de ça que vous venez
juste de me raconter celle qui a fait de
vous le cinéaste que vous êtes encore
aujourd'hui ouais complètement congés du
mois de plus chez ado j'ai une caméra
entre les mains et je filme ça fait à
faire plus de vingt ans je filme et
voilà petit à petit on july moi j'ai pas
fait d'école de cinéma chez un grand fan
de spike lee j'ai moi je m'en étais
inspiré par tous les trous l'américain
les menaces tout society aborigine de
woods plutôt une des films américains
dont quelques français est-il ou dans
votre film les misérables
vous le voyez vous je te vois où l'on
peut on peut imaginer même dans le
personnage de buzz quelque part c'est un
cinéma qui n'existait pas en france
j'ai passé ça ne s'était pas mais voilà
en tout cas on essaie de raconter des
histoires autrement
les premières scènes du film accompagne
une jeunesse dans l'euphorie l'euphorie
de la coupe du monde de football qui
brandir des drapeaux tricolores qui
s'identifie avec liane hem bape et qui
fait exploser sa joie au trocadéro avant
de retourner dans son quartier
je vous propose de regarder une scène
avec moi une scène qui situe un peu plus
tard mais qui n'a pas moins de vitalité
c'est une pleine après-midi sous le
soleil et les enfants sont en train de
jouer avec des pistolets à eau
peut-être que vous pouvez la décrypter
nous a raconté cette scène avec l'image
à l'appui la fameuse scène avec la bande
de microbes et les microbes chez les
ados enfin les jeunes de 10 à 15 ans à
peu près est ce qu'on raconte c'est que
le film se place en planète et donc
c'est un été à la cité la plupart des
ces gosses donc malheureusement n'ont
pas la chance d'aller en vacances donc
il s'improvise un camp club med un club
med en plein milieu de la cité dont ils
ont leur petite piscine gonflable qui se
remplit d'eau des poubelles qu'ils
remplissent d'eau qui servent de
baignoires et les pistolets à eau et
s'amuse à faire une bataille d'eau est
en fait ils attendent je vais pas
raconter toute l'histoire mais il met
une bataille d'eau qui va se réparer
avec avec les gars de la bac
c'est une scène que vous êtes apprêtée
comme vous de jouer un deux roues et
surtout de joie de jouer après ses
décors gillis et des enfants qu'on sait
des enfants et sur live s'amuse même
quand ils s'en prennent aux commissions
l'argonne en sanglots ça reste un jeu ça
reste un jeu pour eux ils savent une
fête le seul moyen qu'ils ont trouvé
pour s'éclater
mais c'est un jeu qui par votre
traitement de cinéma l'âge reste un jeu
mais à quelque chose d'inquiétant
soudain est votre film emprunte parfois
les clichés du thriller horrifique à
l'épouvanté c'est vrai que en regardant
la scène surtout à la fin un petit gamin
qui menace les flics de les gardiens on
peut dire à ce moment là avec la musique
qui arrive que ça risque de partir
quelque part un moment oui non c'est pas
trop parce que ça c'est un sas tiens
c'est pas à quel moment ça va partir et
un moment ça explose on vous dit rien on
ne peut rien dire ça sert d'aller voir
le film aussi beaucoup la haine de
mathieu kassovitz on y pensait tous
quand on a vu cette projection le
mercredi en référence à votre film prix
de la mise en scène la haine à cannes il
ya 24 ans moi j'ai beaucoup pensé à jean
françois richet aussi et à ses deux
premiers films état des lieux et ma cité
va craquer dans quelle mesure ses films
ses trois fils d'ailleurs at il
influencé votre création ou esquisse
leurs morts après le plus cité la haine
parce que c'est un film qui m'a
vachement aspiré est pareil avec
montpellier contre âge mais encore la
craie en 96
la même année la haine de mathieu
kassovitz sort dans les salles et c'est
un film que nous a tous marqués c'est à
partir de là qu'on avait aussi envie de
faire du cinéma qu'on avait envie de
faire des films
donc c'était le point de départ de
kourtrajmé et 24 ans après c'est vrai
que quand on se retrouve à faire un
autre film qui parle des violences
policières on se rend compte que très
peu de choses ont changé malheureusement
en 24 ans ils étaient tous là comme très
gelé ouais la place dans les ténèbres
umaga race ou le désir monde était là
cassel kassovitz voulu lâcher sans ce
qu'ils ont fait dans la création de ce
film les misérables
ils étaient ou pas hésité là près de moi
à me soutenir après chacun développe ses
projets aujourd'hui de son côté mais on
est toujours très solidaire continuent
tous à bosser ensemble mais oui c'est un
soutien c'est un appui je sais que je
peux compter sur eux
rethel à soutenir ya une scène qui m'a
marqué el hadj plutôt une phrase j'ai
marqué je dois vous le dire c'est une
scène de contrôle et est ce policier qui
est un personnage beaucoup plus complexe
on veut bien le croire
qui dit c'est moi la loi alors on
pourrait l'interpréter comme une provoc
comme une allusion cynique et pourtant
les films il n'est pas du tout lentilles
fiq
bien sûr ce que je dis dans le film
c'est les misérables les misérables sans
englobe et la population et les
policiers
aujourd'hui moi je me mets à la place
d'un policier qui l'a qui tournent en
moyenne huit heures par jour dans ces
quartiers difficiles ont des salaires
pas très élevé qui vivent aussi dans des
cités ou dans les hlm quand on prend le
cas la scène où chaque personnage rentre
chez soi la crise 40 chez lui dans un
petit pas régulièrement lieu où adac
habite encore chez sa mère dans un hlm
donc la misère c'est pas que les
habitants c'est aussi des policiers qui
vient cette misère et ça vous l'avez
toujours senti ressenti comme ça ou
alors c'est une réflexion qui a grandit
petit à petit jusqu'à ce film les
misérables
bon je pense que ça a grandi après en
force de la reprise et les fréquentes et
à force de leur parler on se rend compte
que ce n'est pas vraiment de différence
il y avait aussi des situations
précaires et beaucoup d'humour dans
votre film on se souvient d'une scène
dans laquelle un personnage assez
inquiétant dit moi je suis comme miss
france je suis pour l'appeler 30 monde
c'est quoi la fonction de l'humour c'est
vous encore à l'importante toujours en
banlieue quand je vous dis il ya
beaucoup d'humour les gens sont toujours
là et a déconné entre eux à perdre et 20
d'entre eux donc j'ai voulu apporter ce
côté ce côté drôle de mec de quartier et
c'est vrai que le film moi je le trouve
très drôle est hélas par exemple si je
prends le cas hier à la projection
jeunes sont rendus compte que les 25
premières minutes les gens n'osaient pas
rire là qui avait plein de phases
d'arrêt au bout de 25 minutes les gens
commençaient à se lâcher
mais oui il ya des moments très drôles
les idées dire que c'est de l'humour
dans un parfum de fin du monde quand
même et ça c'est un humour en plus chez
lui on sait pas s'il faut rire on sait
pas si c'est moi je trouve ça très drôle
on parle de cette école des cinémas
avons fermé alors vous allez créer l'âge
bien sûr je pars du principe que je
savais faire vingt ans qu'on fait des
films et l'idée aujourd'hui c'est de
partager notre expérience donc j'ai
décidé de monter cette école de cinéma
qui s'appelait des cas
kourtrajmé ont proposé par un ferment de
formation aux métiers du cinéma
scénariste réalisation post production
donc on a annoncé à peu près six mois
pour 30 places on se retrouvait avec
1500 candidature est donc là en trois
mois on a formé une trentaine de jeunes
on l'a dit scénario a abouti ont produit
cinq courts métrages cette année et
l'idée de se développer dès l'année
prochaine en produira 10 films et sur
les dix courts métrages qu'on aura
produit on sélectionne un film pour le
développer en long métrage donc c'est
toute une stratégie qu'on met en place
la france développe partout en afrique
lance au sénégal au mali côte d'ivoire
burkina et le mali et vous par exemple
vous enseigne m moi j'ai fait une master
class aussi la cire quoi cela real voit
sur la real est aussi sur toute mon
expérience c'est surtout mon parcours et
l'idée c'est aussi de leur faire
comprendre qu'on n'est pas obligé de
passer par une école de cinéma
déjà qu'elles sont très difficiles
d'accès en plus à son cher nous l'école
qu'on propose elle est gratuite elle est
ouvert à tous sans condition de diplôme
et donc il suffit d'avoir une idée est
tous motivés en avoir l' envie de faire
du cinéma
poudrier aucun esprit de revanche chez
ou pas n'ont pas du tout pas du tout je
suis comme tous et dans la vie il faut
se battre travaillé dur pour cette
citation de victor hugo
l'afje il n'y a ni mauvaises herbes
dites mauvaises hommes il n'y a que de
nouveaux visiteurs
bien sûr je dis mon film c'est surtout
la fin c'est un cri d'alarmé c'est ce
que je dis c'est un cri d'alarmé qu'on
adresse aux politiques et notamment au
président de la république macro on
aimerait vraiment qu'ils voient ce film
et qui se rend compte de la dure réalité
des choses ce que je dis la prochaine
révolution à partir à ddd quartier moi
je suis convaincu que ça donc il faut
nous entendez faut les écouter on essaie
de trouver des solutions à tous ces
problèmes à ce que vous cherchez à
l'éviter à tout prix
cette révolution bien sûr on a eu des
émeutes de 2005
on se rend compte que douze ans après
rien n'a vraiment changé oui c'est une
phrase de votre sim d'ailleurs à nouveau
dans la position avec les policiers
l'armh en géant
il reste un vieux poteaux les choses
n'ont pas vraiment bougé qu'est ce que
la violence impasse a résolu des choses
on c'est pas moi c'est un comble jeudi 5
raid a l'air attention attention j'ai
pas dévoiler la fin du film mais c'est
attention ça risque de partir en riz les
mauvais cultivateurs sont pas que les
politiques s'y pas noir mais surtout la
faute sur les politiques en ferai comme
je lui dis les policiers je dis pas que
c'est comme dans tout il ya des bons et
des mauvais comme mon lieu il ya des
gens bien des gens moins bien mais c'est
avant tout la faute aux politiques c'est
pour ça qu'on leur lance la pierre alors
dit les gars et entendez nous entende et
nous aujourd'hui elle ce mouvement les
gilet jaune ça fait six mois qu'ils sont
dans la rue qui revendiquent leurs
droits et moi ce que je dis c'est que
nous ça fait 20 ans qu'on est gilet
jaune ça fait vingt encore au mauvais
endroit ça fait 20 ans qu'on subit des
violences policières ça fait 20 ans
qu'on se prend des coulages vont dans la
tête et là dans l'impression avec ce
mouvement le gilet jaune
les français se rendent compte de la
violence des policiers se rendent compte
que la halle by halle est ce dangereux
sauf que nous on a tous subi des coups
de flash ball et ça date pas
d'aujourd'hui quand et quel peut être le
poids d'un film
ladji valider ces deux déjà qu'il soit
vu le fait d'être ici à cannes on espère
que le film traduit dans le monde entier
c'est un film qui part de banlieue mais
c'est avant tout un film universel
vous le savez qu'il va être vous avez vu
le succès pour l'instant elle est plutôt
content et douter c'est que ce soit vu
qu'on relance les débats et comme c'est
de trouver des solutions à tous les
manuels marco pas encore on attendait
son coach pour son coup de fil on lui
dit vous avez on lui dit le président
sur plus appel à johnny ce serait super
les misérables de la dgi avec damien
bonnart et alexis manenti est donc en
compétition à cannes on espère tant le
retrouver au palmarès merci infiniment
fuselage salut à tous
tout de suite la suite